bonjour à tous les versaillais et l'ont
fait ils sont en demi finale de la coupe
de france de football grâce à leur
qualification hier face à bergerac au
terme de la séance de tirs au but les
versaillais qui est vivre un moment
historique moment historique également
pour le département et on sera ce soir
en édition spéciale à partir de 18h sur
tv 78 pour revenir justement sur cet
exploit a invité chronique sujet en
immersion également d'été toute la
journée avec les supporters marseillais
qui ont fait le déplacement à périgueux
oui parce que ce match se disputait à
périgueux et donc je vous le rappelle
édition spéciale à partir de 18 heures
pour revenir sur cet exploit versailles
en demi finale de la coupe de france et
versailles d'ailleurs qui affrontera
l'ogcnice en demi finale